hello guys I'm Greg Alba
a Greg album I'm Brianna white Brianna
white Brianna white rihanna is here
today with me because she is a gamer she
is a lady gamer is that okay to say yeah
lady yang much better yeah sounds cool
yeah it does sounds Pleasant it's also
quite like you know archaic this is a
Kody arkadyich yeah you got it we're
gonna check out the awesome video game
to film adaptation that we've all been
waiting for the Angry Birds official
trailer number two are you excited the
movies coming out you know I don't know
how to react I really don't because I
never really played Angry Birds they
played a little bit of it but I wasn't
like super addicted to it if they can do
a good job then I'll watch the movie
okay you know what I'm gonna give it a
chance open mind here that's awesome you
gotta keep an open mind which one of
those spool secrets to success
happy hats day to you happy hats day
dear Timothy we doll she doesn't like
clothes oh happy hats day to you
that's me red ever since I was a kid I
never really fit in
no one understands me nice chat with you
just you the beer recurring issue eel
egg how thing I have an anger issue I
think you got an anger issue are you
aware that that robe that you're wearing
isn't fooling anybody
voila oh my god greedy from the world of
the pig these pigs for the serious and
weird am i right
I don't trust them I think they're up to
something no opinion is not needy
p-wing giblets that went well
if you're me
set sail for piggy island you tried to
tell us but we didn't listen what do we
do now that is where they went
and so that is where we're going we're
gonna get those eggs back come on you're
offended for dinosaurs we're not
supposed to be nice
yeah point made time to get angry fire
yeah yeah Wow about that she can shoot
fireballs out of her butt
Wow
he's coming back oh did we win can we
get an ice pack for how
Chuck is that you this is the house
first things first
jason sudeikis yeah love him yeah
second thing bill hader love him i'll
watch anything they do jason sudeikis
wasn't in Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs but Bill Hader was the main
voice and that movie was made because of
him
really very funny anytime you have even
if it's animated anytime you have a cast
of comedians mm-hmm I'm down all right
I'm genuinely surprised because I
remember watching the teaser or me and
like this looks delightful looking at
like oh there's a plot here and
everything as a fan of the Angry Birds
game yeah there is a weird thing where
you're like this could have easily been
like a crap yes you know video game
straight-to-dvd adaptation or something
you see on Netflix or something no I
agree and then I'm looking at this one
like they really treated like with a lot
of care I also feel like they gave it a
little extra dose of imagination you
know he wasn't he wasn't just destroying
a casual castle like he went through the
castle and what's it passively it's
really gonna help expand the world and I
like the personality of like this guy
with an angry bird and I'm like when
they actually launched the birds it's
cool that they actually put that in
there and it was like it seemed like
proper reasoning to actually please that
very motivated yeah I just love how you
know they're paying tribute to like you
know he's crashing through everything
again but you see oh just like miserable
user Birds oh I think the writing of the
characters is rather like it's like
studio I'm hoping no we're really hoping
it seems like it's up there with a lot
of good animation it does I'm interested
I'm gonna trust I'm so much I'm gonna
see it I'll I'll keep my fingers crossed
I poke you I hope to be pleasantly
surprised yes I hope you're pleasantly
surprised too I care about your
experience when you watch this movie
because I I'm a good friend there you go
mm-hmm love connection one of the laws
of leadership
Jhansi Maxwell you guys should read it
yeah now it looks like it looks like a
delightful film and thank you guys for
tuning in to the channel listen
subscribe today become a reject boom
shaka laka laka laka brianna white has a
gaming channel called sibling
rivalry if you have a sibling career
occasionally you know you know a battle
with them sometimes the best way to do
is through video games it's actually it
gets vicious it gets addition does we
have these sibling showdown series where
we always play against each other
different games gets pretty intense
oh yeah no Breanna had to get surgery
yeah it was really bad yeah I mean I
surprised that you were able to keep in
that part where he took pliers and pull
that one of your teeth exactly yeah you
know the applicable phrase here really
is if you're not cheating you're not
trying I think you guys have a lot of
things you need to work on it is you
should call it like the sibling abuse
channel if anything you know I think our
name is a little bit more catchy than
that but like good good good input I
will take that away back I will write it
down and send the notebook this videos
over here